hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys wells
jetzt ist ja gerade die kalte jahreszeit
zumindest sollte ist kalt werden
und jetzt ist die zeit für etwas warmes
und zwar gibt es heute etwas aus dem
ofen
ich mache gefüllte paprika mit einer
tomatensoße und ich finde es auch
rezepte die einfach von innen so ein
bisschen wärme
natürlich kann man die auch zu jeder
jahreszeit essen denn man hat im prinzip
keine saisonalen gemüsesorten sondern
paprika gibt's ja im prinzip
mittlerweile das ganze jahr über aus
einer im sommer
ich werde ich jetzt einmal die zutaten
vorstellen falls ihr eine vegetarische
variante machen wollt könnt ihr
natürlich auch das fleisch weglassen ich
benutze jetzt gleich rinderhack fleisch
aber ich habe auch schon mal der version
gemacht mit gefüllten spitz paprika aus
dem ofen und die vegetarisch so war
glaube ich couscous damals drin und
heute eben eine variante mit fleisch für
die zubereitung brauche ich fünf rote
paprikaschoten etwas rapsöl 500 gramm
rinder hackfleisch eine zwiebel 200
gramm preis 100 gramm korinthen 400
milliliter wasser hier vorne habe ich
noch gewürze und zwar einen teelöffel
paprikapulver einen halben teelöffel
kumar und ein viertel teelöffel
kreuzkümmel etwas petersilie einen
teelöffel salz und einen teelöffel
getrocknete minze etwas pfeffer und für
die tomatensoße vier teelöffel
tomatenmark entfährt es als etwas chili
und 100 milliliter wasser zieht jetzt
viel aus aber im prinzip sind viele
gewürze mit dabei und kräuter deswegen
alles andere sind eher so grundzutaten
ich nehme es zuerst einmal so
hackfleisch und zwar wird es jetzt in
einer pfanne beziehungsweise in einem
topf angebraten und zwar auf mittel
hoher hitze mit einem esslöffel rapsöl
kommt vielleicht mit rein und wird es
krümelig angebraten
das heißt ich froh dass ich so lange und
gratis an
es ist eben krümelig wert und die
zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon mal
nutzen und ich sie beschneiden und sie
wird jetzt in würfel geschnitten
sobald es kribbelig angebraten ist
nämlich aus dem topf wieder heraus und
zwar eine saubere schüssel rein
dann kommt das restliche rapsöl also
nochmal einen esslöffel in den topf und
da wird jetzt da wenn die zwiebelwürfel
darin gebraten und zwar so drei bis vier
minuten bis sie glasig sind
als nächstes gehe ich jetzt den reis mit
rein und das auch die korinthen und die
gewürze paprika kurkuma und kreuzkümmel
und es wird jetzt ein bisschen mit
angebratenen bezieht in paris genommen
der hat nämlich mehr vitamine und
mineralstoffe als normaler geschälter
weiterreist und zwar kommt es durch ein
bestimmtes herstellungsverfahren da
wären nämlich die vitamine aus der
schale außen ins innere gepresst und
dadurch hat es eben bis zu 80 prozent
mehr vitamine
aber der reiz hat eine kürzere garzeit
wie jetzt zum beispiel vollkornreis und
die kunden die also im prinzip kennt man
ja eigentlich alles in uns unter dem
begriff rosinen
aber so darf man die gar nicht nennen
denn die korinthen sind einfach die
griechische variante
und das sind die trauben die aus der
stadt korinth kommen in griechenland
deswegen sind es im prinzip griechische
rosinen eigentlich macht nachdem ihr
jetzt kurz angebraten habt kommt jetzt
das wasser mit sein
dann darf das nämlich kurz waren
da kommen jetzt noch salz und die minze
mit rein und auch der zew ihr könnt es
hat sich bei dem rezept auch normale
rosinen nehmen rosinen sind die dunklen
und sultaninen sind die hellen also man
kennt ja auch diese ganz gelben das in
sultaninen und die rosinen kommen meist
aus der türkei als trocknen dann unter
der türkischen sonne und sind etwas
günstiger als die schulter nehmen
oder wenn ihr das ist gar nicht mit dem
leicht süßen da können das natürlich
auch weglassen
wobei es wirklich gut zum geschmack hat
nachdem es jetzt gewürzt habt kommen sie
der deckel drauf und dann darf das ganze
so etwa 10 bis 15 minuten garen bei
mittlerer hitze stell dich mal runter
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt
mich schon mal um die paprikaschoten
kümmern
jetzt nehme ich die erste paprika und
zwar schnell ich jetzt da oben einen
deckel ab und den werde ich später noch
mal benutzen als deckel deswegen so
abschneiden dass er eben nicht kaputt
geht an das innere wird jetzt ausgehöhlt
und wer lust hat kann jetzt hier fordern
noch im gesicht rein schneiden einfach
mit einem messer das werkzeug was ich
verwende ist übrigens im kürbis
schnitzwerk zeug also damit kann man
ganz kurz und halloween kürbisgesichter
einritzen aber könnte es zum beispiel
eben auch für eine paprika oder auch für
wasser meldungen und so weiter wird
der reis ist jetzt geht aber es noch sap
bis fest das heißt noch nicht komplett
weich und die flüssigkeit ist jetzt aber
schon mal weg jetzt kommt da noch die
gehackte petersilie mit rein und auch
das hackfleisch und wie gesagt weil es
vegetarisch machen wollt einfach das
hackfleisch weglassen und einfach mal
ein bisschen mehr reis machen
das wird jetzt kurz durch gerührt und
dann müsst ihr das an der stelle schon
mal ein bisschen abspecken
ob noch salz und pfeffer fehlt aber bei
mir stimmt das jetzt so und dann kann
ich jetzt die paprikaschoten damit
befüllen
die paprikaschoten sind jetzt gefüllt
ich habe jetzt noch zwei mehr gefüllt
denn je nachdem wie groß oder wie klein
sie sind ab dem 5 oder mehr
im prinzip wird es jetzt noch für zwei
weitere ausreichend aber ich lasse den
reise zu und gibt da ein bisschen wasser
mit rein da kann ich hier nochmal ein
bisschen garen und die er lag an den
dann so essen ohne die paprika außenrum
kann ich dir schon mal in einem bräter
setzen jetzt nimmt sie eine auflaufform
oder zum beispiel so ein beredter
umsetzt die teils alle rein
jetzt machen die tomatensauce und zwar
verrät jetzt einfach tomatenmark wasser
und die gewürze und die er lacht puzzle
ich habe natürlich nichts mit über mit
gedacht ich hab mich natürlich jetzt mit
aufgeschrieben oder mit gemerkt weniger
deckel wozu gehört eben was alles schön
sortiert
aber ich nicht so schlimm wasser mit
reinen und jetzt kurz verrühren
die tomatensoße wird jetzt hier darüber
gegossen
und dann kommen noch einmal 200
milliliter wasser hier rein das spüre
ich jetzt kurz aus und geht es in die
mitte so dass die paprikaschoten
leistungen an den topfboden ankleben
jetzt kommt auch der deckel drauf
die paprikaschoten kommen jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad ober
unterhitze etwa 30 minuten
während die fachlichkeit machen brauchen
ist werde ich noch eine joghurt soße
zubereiten
deswegen nehme ich jetzt 500 gramm
stichfesten joghurt de hat zehn ihr
könnt natürlich auch einen namen mit 35
prozent
allerdings ist es sehr schön cremig und
deswegen nehme ich den ganz gerne
da kommt jetzt noch ein bisschen club
auf betreiben der wird fein gerieben
ich nehme jetzt auch nicht zuviel etwas
salz und pfeffer und spaß im prinzip
dann auch schon
jetzt nur noch kurz durchführen und dann
kann ich im prinzip noch auf die
paprikaschoten warten und wird gleich
beides servieren
die paprikaschoten sind jetzt fertig und
murat darf probieren
also ich find sie den wunderschön aus
die suche ist doch gut wenn sind ja
jetzt nicht immer hat vorhin schon den
reis gegessen
ohne paprika
mit dem gesicht richtig herbstlich
gruselig und das amt bliebe gesichter
das sind choristen drin
die mag nicht jeder deswegen habe ich
gesagt man kann sie natürlich auch
weglassen ich es die paprika gerne mit
joghurt moralisch nicht so der joghurt
fans aber ich glaube den fetten joghurt
den markstart den cremigen okay ich
probier setzt er die perser essen glaubt
konnten oder rosinen gerne und er im
reis alles sei keine ahnung der
jugendklasse ich bin da braucht man auch
nicht mehr als gut gemacht aber ich hab
ein bisschen abkühlen lassen damit du
dich nicht verbrennen
also ich mag die kombination total gerne
mit dem bissfesten reis mit den gewürzen
und dann noch die kurve und wahnsinn man
merkt gar nicht dass kein fleisch fisch
fleisch dran ich mich echt klasse mit
dem korinthen das ist toll finde
manchmal die korinther gar nicht also
ich finde man schmeckt herausgeben so
eine leichte süße passen wirklich sehr
gut zu dem anderen witzigen teil
und dann der kante joghurt dazu mache
auf jeden fall in die moto2 klasse
das video endet dass ich am besten kann
sie auch lust habe auf dieses rezept in
jedoch senders - trotz der stets noch
mal ganz genau und ich wünsche ganz viel
spaß beim nachkochen wie gesagt je
nachdem wie groß die paprikaschoten sind
ist noch nicht mehr oder weniger aber
das rezept reicht etwa locker vier bis
sechs personen
nachdem ob er eben noch eine vorspeise
mit dazu ist oder nicht ist das foto
schon gemacht kann ich es vergessen
kannst alles es ist ja okay und ich kann
jetzt auch ersten also bis dann tschüss
gesagt dass noch andere paprika dem ach
so kann man natürlich auch also statt
der roten kann man auch gelb oder grün
nehmen
aber mir persönlich schmeckt rot und
gelb am besten kann mich auf jeden fall
also bis dann